it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PS Morgan un sense and
more anguish for families of the Hamas
hostages as the clock ticks down on
Israel's temporary ceasefire I'll talk
to a daughter of a man still being held
captive by the terrorists after her
mother was
released she soon next number the Greek
Prime Minister as an ancient row over
the Elgen marbles becomes a modern day
diplomatic spat is it time we just let
them back we'll
debate and Dr gabo Mar is the infant
Holocaust Survivor his powerful take on
the Gaza War as one plaud it across the
world he also says he bitterly regrets
GRS ever interviewing Prince Harry I'll
find out
[Music]
why from the news building in London
this is Pier's Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to Pi Morgan uncensored a debate
about whether the Elgen marble should
leave or remain is almost as old as the
marbles themselves those who want them
to stay in the British museum are
worried it'll open the floodgates they
say countries around the world will
begin demanding the return of all our
Colonial Treasures leaving the British
museum looking like Tottenham hotspur's
trophy cabinet I've sympathized with
that opinion in the past but for me what
it came down to was this argument from
the Greek prime minister at the weekend
this is not an in my mind an ownership
question this is an a reunification
argument where can you best appreciate
what is essentially one Monument I mean
it's as if if if I told you that you
would cut the monaa in half and you
would have half of it at the Lou and
half of it at the British museum do you
think your viewers would appreciate the
the beauty of the painting in such a way
well this is exactly what happened with
a
paron sometimes somebody makes a point
it's so compelling that it compels even
people like me to change my mind Greece
has built a spectacular Museum to show
off the pathon marbles as they call them
but with plastic casts of the marbles
were the real ones really ought to be
they were brought to Britain by Lord
Elgen who paid a fortune to extract them
and later sold them to the government
after a very expensive divorce he always
claimed he had the permission from the
Ottoman Empire which controlled Athens
at the time but as the Greek PM says
it's not really an argument about
whether a British Aristocrat filled out
the right paperwork the British museum
could still own the marbles but but also
loan them back to Greece as it does with
many thousands of other artifacts every
single year Britain's always said these
Treasures should stay here where they're
safe th an argument become a lot less
sturdy since the museum admitted it's
lost more than 2,000 Treasures worth
several million pounds how safe is that
exactly when that's become a Full
Throttle diplomatic spat after our prime
minister rishy sunak canceled a meeting
with his Greek counterpart at the last
minute seemingly angry about what he
said on the BBC at the weekend this
seemed a pretty chish if not Petty
attempt to Panda to his base and not a
good look for either the prime minister
or our country Greece is one of our
allies their friends they gave us feta
cheese olive oil stavos flatly it's time
we gave them our marbles in return we'll
be debating that later in the show but
first night tonight despite the release
of more than 60 hostages the harrowing
weight goes on for many families
awaiting news of their loved ones Israel
says that its youngest hostage
shamefully a 10-month-old baby has been
handed to another terror group meaning
Hamas is no longer in control of that
poor child's fate well yoked lifshitz
was abducted by herass for 16 days later
released on October the 23rd memorably
shaking hands with one of her captiv
however her husband odad lifshitz
remains in captivity and their daughter
Chiron lifshitz joined me now shiron
thank you so much for joining me to
tonight I really appreciate it first of
all let me just say your story has been
one of the stories out of this hellish
situation that's touched me the most I
think anyone uh who has parents are
still alive uh would have I think had
their hearts just wrenched by what's
happened to you the idea that on that
awful day October the 7th you lost both
of them and had no idea what had
happened to either of them and then you
have the joy of your mother returning
but you have the despair of still not
knowing where your father is so first of
all let me just say my my heart goes out
to you and to your family for what
you've had to go through it is it is an
unrelenting horror and it must have been
incredibly stressful um but second let
me just take you back to October the 7th
let me just ask you when was the first
you knew about what was happening that
day
I was um we got up early with my son and
my husband to go up north to York we
live in London um for to pick up a puppy
actually that we've been planning for
months um and I opened some news outlet
and so that it flared up I called my mom
as I always do and I couldn't get a hold
of her I then called my brother and he
told me that there's been a barage of
missiles and now they broke the fence
and that was how it
started and they didn't just break the
fence they of course attacked a number
of kutas including near o where your
parents uh lived and had lived for a
very long time when was the moment that
you discovered that they had both
disappeared been
taken so it's been a long day and we
were on WhatsApp group with other
members of the kots people were
desperately trying to help it other to
devise way to contact other people we
were on the news it was a horrific day
about an hour and a half later I saw the
eljer clip with the
journalist um saying about the fact
they're occupying the kots and this was
actually just behind my parents house
and so by that point I knew that things
were are never going to be the same but
then we had many hours hearing so many
rumors and um hearing um stories from
people and about 8:00 in the evening um
it took 8 hours for the Army to arrive
in the kibot and not one shot was really
shot at the terrorist they came in they
did what they wanted they went as far as
they could and then they left so we
heard about 8:00 in the evening that my
parents were missing from the room in
retrospect we know that the whole house
was bad learning but we were spare that
knowledge at the time absolutely
horrifying it turned out your mother
who's 855 years old had been kidnapped
by Hamas gamman on motorbikes and taken
into what was described as a spider's
web of tunnels underneath Gaza um did
did you have any knowledge about where
she'd been taken or what was happening
to
her well my my mom and dad were in the
bedroom it was quite early in the
morning they arrived late my father
didn't feel well so they basically had
the terrorist the last my father spoke
was to a friend and he said I can hear
them speaking Hebrew I can hear many
shootings and shortly after that that we
lost connection with them then they we
know now we knew afterwards that it they
there were shots in the door at that
time we thought they were taken together
at that time we were just desperate
thinking they probably didn't survive or
their health is too
frail and um when my mom came out of the
ground it was like a miracle because we
really didn't know that she was
alive and just seeing her face seeing
her gesture and then she told us that
our father was uh shot and that he was
injured and so we we my mom was very
pessimistic and so for for the last
month we've just been really so
pessimistic about the uh chance of
somebody has old and frail and with
complicated medical needs to survive
this uh ordeal and then about three or
four days ago with the first uh women
and children that came one of the
hostages actually told us that she was
with my father in in the same space for
several days that he was injured in his
legs from being drugged you know uh when
they he was being pulled that he was
injured in his hand but uh that he was
alive and and that's really the first
time we heard he's alive at the same
time we also hearing more and more and
more stories about the horrific
conditions that they're subjected to and
so many of them did not receive medicine
even simple medicine that over 50
something days can really cause huge
medical problems everything is a problem
there there's levels of torure to think
that they're on a Holiday Camp is is
part of the psychological warfare being
waged against us it's it's mindblowing
to me what you're having to endure here
uh along with all the relatives of
course of all these hostages because the
people that were taken were in the main
either elderly or they were children
baby in some case it's it's it's beyond
horrific um but I guess that you've had
some great news obviously that your
mother came out and you've also had some
great news you at least you know that as
of several days ago your father's still
alive that must be a huge Comfort to you
notwithstanding the fact he's still
trapped inside
Gaza well we know he was alive about
over a month ago that's where we
estimate that they or spat that uh
hostage that return and my father so we
we do not know and the situation is
absolutely desperate absolutely horrific
I think that uh Alma Abrahams that came
she came back in a really bad condition
just purely due to neglect for the fact
she was not getting her medicine these
are innocent people that were elderly
people that were dragged from them home
um that saw their families being
murdered
these are people that are coming back to
such a complicated altered reality you
know we are uprooted our homes are
destroyed uh people coming back but they
don't know their their brother or their
son was murdered that you know it's
wonderful to have them back they are our
light at this great Darkness your father
was a very well-known peace activist who
would drive sick Palestinian children to
hospitals in Israel he spent his life in
the peace movement this is what he
wanted was to have two Nations living
peacefully side by side and he believed
you would make peace with your enemies
this has been what his life's been about
uh and yet there he is now uh in Gaza
being held by terrorists and you've no
idea what may happen to
him yeah I think my father story
complicate this situation for people who
would like to just cheer for one team
and I think that in this part of the
world there are many people that realize
that our capacity to live peacefully is
only if we find a way to live peacefully
alongside our neighbors Shon I I'm so
sorry for what you're going through I
said it at the start I'll say it again
now it's it must be Agony for you and I
hope your father is released very soon
that your family can be reunited but as
you say it's it's so much more than just
them you know they lived in a kabut with
400 people 80 at least were killed in
the most barbaric manner these are
people they've known sometimes for
decades close friends um and the horror
of that well I'm sure we'll live with
all of them uh the ones who survived for
a very long
time yeah um you know it's it's amazing
how when your life is kind of torn apart
so much you realize the kind of fabric
and what it is made of and how the love
that we share the way you overcome Petty
fights you used to have over little
things and in a way in all this Darkness
it's these people some of them you know
I lived in London for 30 years I went
really far and I see people I haven't
seen for 20 years and there's a bond and
a you know Destiny has brought us back
together and I think that that's
something that really carries us through
it the feeling that we are part of this
extended Community even if we're very
far
away and I think also you know people
have sh shown great generosity and
kindness towards us and in a way that
also makes me feel that you know that we
will have to find a way forward to this
the legacy of these events and we are
learning every day new things we are
learning about rape and we are learning
about beheading and we are learning
there's thousands of stories and the
ordinary stories are just things that
would have you know been covered in the
news for weeks for one of them and
there's thousands and thousands of these
stories the scale of it is is
overwhelming there's there were 240
hostages we're now down to 166 many of
them are you know connected to other
hostages to people that were murdered I
my heart is with all all of them with
the fathers who were there so there's
children who came back to find that
their parents were murdered there's
children who came back knowing that
their father is still there and they
don't know when they will see him
there's such a huge level of trauma
there's such a complicated situation
that unfolds here sometime it makes you
feel really so desperate and yet you
know I I know because I'm a parent
myself that we have to come out of it
and let it be the Catalyst for more than
just more war shiron this is a difficult
question but I'm curious what you feel
about this is obviously Israel's
response has been uh militarily uh
overwhelming in Gaza a lot of
Destruction many homes uh wiped away U
tens of thousands now of Palestinians
have been killed including thousands of
children obviously had nothing to do
with any of this what do you feel about
the Israeli
response as a human being I I find a
loss of life and I spend quite a lot of
my time reading about it and trying to
educate myself about it I find this loss
of life
horrific I also find that on this there
was a very frail coexistence that was
shuted on the 7th of October
and it's very hard to understand to me
at this moment what is a good response
and what isn't I think that we are
dealing with a horrific uh terrorist
organization that is worse than Isis
it's worse than k then B Haram and so
it's very easy to just say don't do
anything but I don't know then what do
you suggest one thing I know for sure is
that it cannot possibly be that the
people who have you know come to us and
raped and Slaughter and murdered us and
trained for it and premeditated every
element of it I cannot believe that
these people come back home and are kind
to their own people so I think that the
Palestinian people deserve better than
Hamas too and I think that that is
something I'm sure about it I'm not a
military strategist and I'm running on
the pitch like hell trying to save my
life one my loved on so it's not the
best moment for me to kind of uh think
about what is the best strategy for it I
lament tremendously the loss of life I
believe still that we will have to make
peace with our enemy one way or another
I believe that the my people have
endured such a horrific trauma that I
you know we cannot contain it we cannot
contain it we cannot contain the mass
rapes we cannot contain the killing of
babies the tearing out of babies out of
the mothers we cannot contain it so at
this point it's really hard for me to
tell you what will be a good strategy
yes you know I don't know I know what I
want I want nobody to suffer from this
ever yes I completely agree with you and
it's you say it so eloquently and so
powerfully just just finally shran how
are you doing this must have been the
worst time of your life of course but
how you how are you coping are you
sleeping are you are you getting enough
support I feel very surrounded by love I
spend a lot a lot of time with my mom my
mom you know life has changed so much
we're just trying to relocate her and
find our feet in a you know my parents
house was the center of our world all of
us are all of a sudden on the world
stage playing you know for to the
audience I don't know how to say it and
it's just been really really exhausting
and it feels that we need so much
strength we also know that we have found
our voice and strength in the last 53
days in a way we could never foresee and
uh I think that we are carried by sheer
fact that we have to do it as well as by
the fact that something should come out
of it we we owe it to the people that
are there and I think the fight is
working this deal is the most important
thing we need to now continue it very
very very very carefully make sure that
it's not going to be stopped in the next
two days but that it continues to the
full maximum and then we have to press
on all governments on the Qatari on the
Egyptian on NOS that have failed us
miserably uh on the seven and since on
all these people we have to press on
them to continue to bring these people
back home and then we can start really
thinking what has happened what could be
done differently you know whether Israel
later now it's just about returning
returning these people home they are in
horrific condition their life might end
very quickly for all sorts of various
reasons I call on everybody who can do
anything to bring them back home to end
that stage and then we can look for how
to move on shiron thank you so much for
joining me I wish you and your family
all the best I hope and pray your father
is home with you soon uh but I thank you
for joining me and I wish you and all
the families of all these hostages uh
who are living this unrelenting
nightmare I hope it is over soon for all
of you thank you very much thank you
thank
you well sensor next he's the Jewish
Holocaust Survivor whose powerful take
on the Gaza war is one plaudit across
the world Dr Gabel Marte who also
famously interview Prince Harry decision
he came to regret joins me next
[Music]
live we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online run your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well Tred most dog owners will tell you
a dog can turn do you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police a pro Palestine that is just
not right you swearing off in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million4
million so far so1 140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about 3 years hundreds and hundreds
of mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
Phil sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party hi
off kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group of
a rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
welcome back to un sensor Dr Gabriel
Marte made Global headlines early this
year when you appeared in an interview
with Prince Harry the renowned trauma
expert spoke with the juk of susex about
the importance of healing in an
interview to promote Harry's Memoir well
more recently Dr Marty has been winning
plaudit for his take on the Israel Hamas
War he's an infant survivor of the
Holocaust has been outspoken about both
the atrocities of October the 7th and
Israel's response and Dr Gabel Marte
joins me now Dr Marty thank you very
much indeed for joining me and thank you
for your patience I know you've been
sitting there listening to the interview
I just conducted uh with this poor woman
who whose parents were both kidnapped
one has been returned one hasn't yet
first of all what was your response to
to that
interview um on the human level I saw a
very decent person in evident pain in
grief um obviously deep anxiety about
the fate of her father I saw somebody
trying to make the best um out of a
really horrific situation and my heart
goes out to
her you human level specialize
throughout your career in in trauma and
helping people get through trauma you've
talked to many people who been in
extreme trauma this is a very traumatic
situation these last two months for
people on both sides for the people uh
who were on the receiving end of this
massacre on October the 7 7th we've just
heard firsthand what that has been like
for the people in Israel who suffered
that but also of course what's going on
now in Gaza with you know many thousands
of innocent people uh being killed uh
with Israel's military response
including thousands of children um what
is your overall assessment of of where
this war is now
heading for that you need some
historical context now look I used to be
a Zionist I'm a as you mentioned I'm a
holocaust Survivor Zionism was very
important for me as a Salvation of the
Jewish
people until I found out that the state
was founded based on the extration the
explosion and multiple massacres of the
local population and that's not
historically
controversial so I'm taking a longer
riew of this and I'm saying that the
present situation cannot be be
understood without looking at the
historical context and nor can we move
forward if the present occupation and
the suppression of the Palestinians
continue so Sheron your previous guest
talked about the fragile coexistence
there was no coexistence there was
oppression periodic massacres um uh land
occupation um in the West Bank the
continuous exposion of the population
from their homes I visited the occupied
territories three times now the first
time back during the first in the appear
I cried every day out for two weeks at
what I saw so this cannot go on and I
saw the news about the Elgen marbles
being returned and how you changed your
mind about that well how about returning
the land that's been stolen from the
Palestinians I'm not talking about the
state of Israel I'm not talking about
1948 I'm talking about since 67 and
what's going on right now so there's got
to be some stop to what's going on and
that's how I understand it no this is
for the sake of both Israelis and
Palestinians yes I I completely agree
with you this is a NeverEnding cycle I I
guess from the israeli's point of view
what happened on October the 7th was on
such a gigantically horrific scale I do
get a sense that Israel is in a
collective sense of trauma and and that
they are determined that Hamas should
not be allowed to perpetrate such a
massacre again and they are on record
Hamas just two weeks ago their spokesman
are saying they would do it again and
again and again if they can so that
represents a clear existential threat to
the security of people in Israel so I
guess my my question for you is what
should Israel's response be everyone is
increasingly concerned about what is
going on in Gaza clearly the loss of
civilian life is on a a catastrophic
scale nobody thinks this is right but at
the same time I think many would share
my view that Israel has a right to
defend itself the question is how do
they do that appropriately and how do
they get rid of Hamas if indeed you
think they should get rid of
Hamas while you're raising many
questions and many fair questions now
look I live in Canada where this country
was founded on the supre ression and the
Eraser of the indigenous population and
the utter denial of their
narrative and uh in Canada for example
there the horrendous residential schools
where a few decades ago if a native
child spoke their tribal language they
have a pin stuck in their tongue now
most Canadians are not aware of that
history most Israelis are not aware of
the history of what the Palestinians
have suffered they don't know that in
1948 there were multiple massacres of
large numbers of people by Israeli
forces they don't know the history the
subjective experience of the
Palestinians and in the absence of that
knowledge October 7th would just strike
them as another horrific anti-semitic
event I understand the desire for
defense and certainly even a desire for
Revenge but that's in the absence of
knowing what the Palestinian experience
has been and the Western press and as in
all countries where the local population
has been displaced the majority of the
population doesn't know the history or
the subjective experience so if you're
asking me how to move forward let's
inform ourselves of the actual
experience of both sides not just one
side and just as you had this wonderful
Israeli woman um shaon here who spokes
with such humanity and such poignancy
you you might have some Palestinians on
explaining their experience of what it's
like for them to live under occupation
and in the absence of that conversation
there's no moving forward and that's all
I'm asking for I've had a number of uh
Palestinians including adop let me say
one more thing sorry yeah Israel's right
to defense yes Israel has the right to
defend itself every country does but
Israel has no right to impose an
occupation on people now look I was born
in Hungary in 1956 when I was 13
studying for B Mitzvah there was the
great Hungarian Revolution against
Soviet
occupation and uh it was after that
Revolution that we became refugees and
came to Canada now did Russia have the
right to defend itself against the
Hungarian
revolutionaries you know so and and
mostly when we talk about Israel's right
of Defense we're taking isolated
Palestinian actions but we're not saying
that this population also has the right
to defend Gates of against the
occupation I'm not justifying the the
terrible events of October the 7th I'm
talking in the absence of historical
awareness it all just looks like Israel
defending itself but against whom
against the population that has been
massacring in a number of thousands for
80 years and taking their lands and
destroying their homes and jailing their
children and torturing them that's the
history
now unless we know that it all looks
like this poor little country trying to
defend itself but against
whom against people that's been
occupying and displacing for 80 years
that's the history as Israeli historians
have shown I don't make this stuff up I
wish it wasn't true I wish I would
believe in the dream of the Jewish State
I love that dream except I found out at
what price at what nightmare that
imposed on the
Palestinians how do you see this ever
getting resolved it seemed so
intractable but then as I always say so
did the Northern Ireland conflict that
seemed intractable when the IRA were
committing uh Terror atrocities but they
eventually did get to peace can you see
a pathway here to peace and what does it
look
like does
it I can that's a great question again
look you're can to have Nick K was on
later on the tennis player I just spent
a couple of weeks in Serbia um and the
former Yugoslavia with another tennis
player Novak jokovic they have a
foundation that promotes healing and
Child Development and so on so they
asked me to speak throughout the former
Yugoslavia you know what
horrific um
um atrocities were committed there just
a few decades ago
so I was in Belgrade I was in
Saro I was in baluca I was in
yuana they're living together now there
are still issues to be worked out but
the minimum condition is the ending of
the occupation and the inhumane Siege of
Gaza and international law has to be
respected international law is very
clear that this occupation is illegal
that has to be the basis of any future
agreement if that was agreed on and if
Israel could live within the borders
that are internationally
recognized I believe peace is possible
now we keep talking about the hamash
charter did you know that the liud
charter the ruling part in Israel
excludes a Palestinian entity west of
the Jordan River so let's get rid of
both Charters and let's start with the
basis of recognition and and peace and
the ending of this unspeakably brutal
occupation Fe you have to go there to
see it for yourself as I have and you
would cry every day for two weeks as
well I'm under No Illusion about what
the Palestinian people have had to
endure and I think the the oppression of
the Palestinian people for decades has
been completely shameful and it
shouldn't have been happening I mean the
mere fact that Israel was able after
October the 7th to Simply turn off the
supplies of food and water and fuel and
so on into Gaza says it all that that is
a an occupation that is a controlling
Force controlling whether people eat or
have fuel or can heat themselves or feed
themselves um so I I you know I I I'm
under no Illusions about that I'd be
very critical of Israel before what has
complicated things for me morally with
this is that the scale of what happened
on October the 7th was so disgusting uh
and the fact that Hamas has said they
will continue to try and do the same
thing again is that I I absolutely
believe Israel has to do what it can to
remove that threat and how you do that
when they are immersed in the civilian
population and that population is half
children uh without massive civilian
casualties on the scale we're now seeing
I don't know I genuinely don't know I
don't know how they resolve this but uh
I hope that better Minds than mine can
work our way through
this
well I hope along with you as well but
again I'm saying that there's no
possibility of that until the
interational until the International
Community and particularly Israel's Big
Brothers the UK and the US stop
supporting its illegal brutal inhumane
and rapacious occupation it can't happen
without some pressure um and again most
Israelis are simply not aware I've been
to Israel talk to people they have no
idea what's happening a few miles away
from when they're sitting in Tel Aviv
having coffee and they have no idea or
in Jerusalem and they have no idea
what's happening a few miles away how
those people under occupation are living
and this has been dog it's not that
they're not capable of being aware but
like most people they just not and I'm
saying that unless we fully get the
palestin experience
historically and throughout the decades
and into the present moment we can't
possibly understand what's going on here
now in 2005 there was a a study appeared
in the Journal of world Psychiatry
looking at
traumatized populations under War
conditions the most traumatized children
in 2005 this is before Hamas gained
power in h in Palestine and in Gaza the
most traumatized kids were in
Gaza this population has been
traumatized
severely of course they're full of Rage
I'm not justifying anything they did but
I'm saying what do we expect from this
population that's been suppressed and
tormented and crucified for decades
sorry we're going to have a short break
and come back I'll come back with you
after the
break we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well do
you know what I love about talk today we
do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that it's just not right you swear an o
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a tragedy
there needs to be one human per machine
to come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a living if you're
walking towards me and you're a vegan
you have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegan about
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you this is a
major Summit President Biden decided
this was important after watching a Tom
Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call her is it possible
to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
[Music]
truth
this is talk
[Music]
TV wcome back to on sens Dr Gabel Marte
still with me Dr Marte I want to talk to
you about something else now which made
you globally uh brought to the world's
attention early this year when you sat
down with Prince Harry to talk about his
book spare and he got a lot of attention
this I just wondered you've expressed
since then regret really that you ever
did it uh why do you feel that
way I express regret not about the uh
having done the interview but the way I
agreed that it would be um conducted
what I mean by that is I had a strong
sense that this should intervie should
be free for everybody it should be a
service to the public it was a great
discussion I really enjoyed meeting
Harry I found him to be humble and
sincere and genuinely interested in
promoting mental health and looking at
the trauma that underlies people's
mental health issues what was wrong with
it is that was put behind the pay wall
so a lot of people people had to buy his
book in order to watch the interview a
lot of four million people already had
they were excluded from watching the
interview and so that's what I regretted
I did not regret doing the interview I
enjoyed it and I thought it was a really
good discussion between two people two
to flaw people who were willing to look
at their flaws so I um I'm glad I did it
but in retrospect I would not agree to
it unless it was aired freely for the
whole world to see Harry felt the same
way by the way afterwards we both wanted
it released but the lawyer said that
since it was marketed as a pay for
viewing onetime event we' be slapped
with a clash acction suit if we released
it so unfortunately Ely a lot of people
didn't see it those who did for the most
part a lot of appreciation let me let me
play a clip from the interview you
conducted I'll come back to you after
this and then at some point you say
towards the end of the
book when is someone in this family
going to break free and live have you
done that I have now yeah um what does
it feeling it was great I do I you once
the book came out I felt I felt incred
got to be free I felt a huge weight off
my
shoulders now we have very different
views about Prince Harry I'll lay my
cards on the table I I think he's
behaved disgracefully towards his family
particularly when Prince Phillip was
dying then the queen was dying the
family was in grief and all he and his
wife Megan seem to have done to me is
Chuck Flames at the family from abroad
and tried to damage them and the
institution of the monarchy but it's
interesting that he believed there and I
recognize you feel differently he
believed that that he's found freedom
but in all your experience of talking to
people through you know similar kind of
family trauma if you like can you really
find happiness if your freedom involves
disconnecting yourself from your entire
family well it's a really good question
my eldest son and I Daniel with whom I
wrote our book The Myth of normal trauma
illness and and healing in a toxic
culture are writing a new book now it's
called hello again a fresh start for
parents and their adult children
families are tough families hurt each
other children are traumatized in
families Harry was traumatized in his
family not because his parents didn't
love him but because they were carrying
their own trauma and passing it on to
the next Generation I passed on my
trauma to my children I didn't mean to
but I did and so
sometimes people can work these things
out if there's the willingness on both
sides and people do make mistakes and I
do believe Harry made some
mistakes um that goes both ways um
people can work it out and sometimes
they can't and sometimes people find
Freedom in having to disconnect in in
the book The Myth the normal I talk
about this tension that we all have
between authentic and belonging
attachment and authenticity if we can
belong and connect and be our true
selves that's ideal but what do we do if
in order to be our true selves our
families or our communities won't accept
us well for example over this Israel
issue I made a decision a long time ago
that for me speaking the truth which
doesn't make me right but speaking my
truth is more important than who likes
me and who doesn't like me in 19 1967 I
wrote an article after the war arguing
by that time that Israel had occupied
these territories quite deliberately and
then never give them back my father
kicked me out of the
house I accepted that now my father
later on came around and actually agreed
with me but I made the decision that to
be myself and to speak my truth I'm
willing to break the contact if that's
what it
took a lot of people in that situation
and and Harry in that family with a very
troubled young mother and a Loveless
marriage and a father was having a fair
before he was born a family that was not
a whole lot of taching and holding
there's multiple reasons to say that it
was a very traumatized child and in
order to become himself he had to
distance himself now did he do it right
exactly the ideal way maybe not but you
know what when I look at myself at age
38 or 35 five boy did I make a lot of
mistakes so this is all part of the
human drama and families sometimes work
it out sometimes they don't it's true
it's very true Dr Mar I've got to leave
it there it's been fascinating please
come back on the show again another time
I've really enjoyed talking to
you likewise I really appreciate you
giving me this uh this listening thank
you a pleasure thank you very much on
says next is it time to give the Elgen
marbles back to Greece we'll
debate
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
sport today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon had the other
the police appr Pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it don't know whether it's
a FSE or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million1 140
million pound so far so40 million pounds
so far results nil absolutely nil are we
only going to be trusting sources like
meta and Google where is our unbias news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that's is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man M he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice
this is a major Summit President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what's what what's fair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV it's the
only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to joh S I'm joining
Now by my pack talk to be contributor
paulone agan the former Marine term
presenter and conservationist James
clany and political journalist AA
Santina right let's talk marbles Mr
clany because you and I don't agree
about this I've had I've had a
conversion the Greek Prime Minister
actually changed my mind when he painted
this picture literally of the Mona Lisa
cut in half and said what would you feel
about that I thought he's right surely
the right thing to do is to bring the
two parts together and actually if you
look at the history and you look at
where they want to put it it makes more
sense that we just loan it back to them
doesn't it I'm not massively passate
about the marbles I think the biggest
mistake was rishy um snubbing Greek P
that that's the that's what's made this
much bigger look the the major I do
agree with the government is once you
start giving back one artifact it's like
pulling the thread we do give a lot of
artifacts away we do we do we give
thousands away all the time we lend
stuff to museums around the world what's
the difference oh yeah that that's the
right word we're lending things but if
you saw earlier this year that the COO
the diamond in um in the crown Jews um
worn by the lake Queen Mother there's
now cause for that to be returned to
India and thousands of other artifacts
as soon as you do one it's going to go
on and on and on all right AA what's
your response to that well maybe you
should no I mean what's the argument for
us keeping hold of it forever you know
if if I was sitting here wearing I don't
know one of your jackets you'd probably
ask for it back wouldn't you well it
depends how you acquired it I mean some
of these things if they're looted then
so if you let me borrow it for one
minute and I kept it forever you might
have something to say the point about
the marbles which they call the path on
marbles right or whatever they call them
they the the point about them is there
is a dispute over actually the original
propriety right we know that one of our
Aristocrats bought it back but that was
from the Ottoman Empire of the time who
were the ruling power in in Athens at
the time but that is disputed it's not
like this is clean cut anyway no
absolutely and a parliamentary inquiry
might have found that he had brought
them back you know above board but I
mean how many times have we sat around
here and disputed what our parliamentary
select committee has had to say I mean
we don't necessarily AG let me ask you I
mean just on a general thing we were
just saying in the break in the general
scheme of things who gives us stuff
about a bunch of marbles right there
Wars raging cost of leave living crisis
we've had a pmic can't we just lend the
marbles back to the Greeks I thought the
prime minister of Greece put up a really
respectful position and he's right it's
we've got two halves of his great work
of art sitting in different countries
they've got to come back together and
actually they began there yes yeah
absolutely the the problem is they
should be returned we know they should
be returned but we're we're we're
fussing over it and we shouldn't be
fussing over it when there are more
serious things to discuss soon shouldn't
be snubbing I like Richie but he
shouldn't be snubbing the prime minister
of Greece they're an ally of ours this
is the problem isn't it with this
meeting because it wasn't just about the
pathon it was also going to be about
Ukraine it was also going to be about
what was happening in Israel and Gaza
these are really important issues um
it's also going to be about you know the
cost of crisis in terms of oil and gas
Etc so there issues close to the heart
of many of the voters here and he
snubbed him so not just about the path
and ons but also very serious home
issues as well okay a let's turn to
Conor McGregor and unlikely segue and I
didn't think I'd be talking about him in
political uh terms but what's going on
in in Ireland is is really quite
terrifying and he's at the center of it
because you're seeing a huge reaction to
what happened with this attack on three
kids and a woman by someone who's
actually a naturalized IR citizen but
came in as Nigerian and this all goes
back to this is ongoing raging issue of
immigration Conor McGregor's put himself
right in the middle of it basically
Ireland were at War what do you make of
this well I mean Conor McGregor is
someone who likes to put himself in the
middle of everything I mean he's a
pretty abor human being by all standards
I mean I think just a couple of years
ago he was filmed punching an old man in
a pub who wouldn't accept a shot of
whiskey from him he's also had many
other sexual assault allegations levied
at him I mean I don't know what what
happened to them but there have been
many of them
heed of any the thing that the thing
that concerns me though and this is
going to be a deeply unpopular point but
it's that to tweet something and then be
investigated for it frightens me because
it's setting a a quite dangerous
precedent well I thought the same about
Tommy Robinson this is what I was being
arrested at the weekend I'm like what
did he do to deserve being arrested I
mean James this is a you know you can
you can uphall the people I actually
like G McGregor for what it's worth but
but in Tommy Robinson's case I have no
Tru with him whatsoever and I think he's
a pretty poisonous individual however I
feel uncomfortable like you did are we
overstretching now in the way we police
these things yeah I mean it clearly
Island isn't at War and he's just thrown
himself in whether he's drunk but I'm
more concerned about the fact that the
police could be knocking at your door
for a tweet I mean we all have emotions
when they're all standing up all turning
up at a peaceful protest and being
apparently peaceful well it's not the
arrest that concerns me the arrest is
fine what concerned me was the use of I
forgotten the spray
that concerns so my understanding in
relation to to Mr lenon Yi lenon was
that there was a Prohibition um so he
wasn't allowed within a particular area
and it was understood that he breached
that order so it wasn't just that he
just I know buts and you know he just
turned up and oh poor poor Tommy that's
not that's not the case secondly in
relation to the police potentially
turning up to arrest you for a tweet
absolutely they should have that right
to be able to do that because if it was
a a tweet that incited hate hatred
incited violence incited someone to
commit a criminal act of course you know
what you never see you never see anybody
on the left arrested for a tweet you
only ever see people on the right guys
we run out of time I'm afraid I'm going
to have to arrest this conversation uh
but it's an interesting debate you know
I think how far we go in policeing these
things is really important both on
social media the police protest marches
and sign got to be consistent thank you
P appreciate it that's it from me
whatever you're up to keep it un
sensored good night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well Tred
most dog owners will tell you a dog dog
can turn you know what I love about talk
today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
done through normalizing relations with
Saudi Arabia the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Ry sunak has done the question
now is what he does next the police are
pro Palestine that is just not right you
swear an o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomim
there's not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a fce or
a tragedy talk TV has spoken exclusively
to a member of the Blade Runners do you
have a message for sadique KH we're not
stopping until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million pound so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold
that is from the Jeremy Corbin B Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his fat ass talking for
liit if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man m m he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of M he
on this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film